il faut que je chante au nom alors bien
c'est moi je suis malheureusement libéré
et j'attends j'attends l'autre savage du
cac
il
sa vague aura bientôt en tout cas
youssoufou souffle et ouais alors et
attend la légion sans ben laden le 2 mai
de cette année de belles à regarder les
mets se rassurent aller
tu fais
voilà
on attend c'est gentillet qui va
fusionner m&j sans rigoler on dirait tir
audio en direct c'est bien de faire des
travaux le garde
james avait collé à louga alors c'est
bon pour le plateau pas sur le premier
étage sont des blancs ou pas alors on y
va
libéré
non
coucou ib regard des allocs
c'est pas possible je vous adore et les
coudes adore vraiment bien et bravo
thierry moreau c'est grâce à vous parce
que vous avez donné une bonne réponse
bravo vous titille attention alors on en
est ou sur twitter germanium envers
points s'il a beaucoup je te dis papa a
bien sûr hashtag base dibaba si vous
voulez que je serais tout à fait si je
termine derrière vous avez je me tiens
très généreux il ajouté